future state for agencies in terms of if
I were to start today and I had to be
within that sphere is that I would be
looking at the stop Gap and then recruit
the people to build the department out
ultimately most business owners want
that it's a much more valuable solution
if you're saying I'm going to build this
department with you it's also
automatically a much longer sale which
means your LTV will probably be
significantly longer because
fundamentally if you can get all the
skills that you have put into their
business you've cloned your agency in
their business and made it significantly
more valuable it also accounts for their
fear which is well there's two scenarios
for the business owner either I pay you
and you suck or the other bad scenarios
I pay you and you're amazing and you own
me if I were the salesman selling this
thing I'd be like here are your two
options with the current state I want to
show you door three which is I am really
good but I'm going to build this so that
you're not dependent on me